hello everybody welcome to part 6 of
let's play penumbra overture as you can
tell my save drop me somewhere else so
I'm going up oh oh I tapped out a
message I gotta keep it consistent what
miss I forget it
oh and then I uh let's see what I did oh
I looked at this useless thing and then
I went up here and then I got scared of
a dog Oh Oh a dog Oh and then I fell and
hurt myself
BAM okay all right yeah I'm oh yeah and
I mocked the dog hot dog you so fat and
ugly or look at you
oh you legs are narrow alright that's
enough and then I think I went to the
power room yeah yeah yeah it's all about
consistency to be oh I bang on this
thing I feel I know boom bang you bang
alright that's enough of that
oh and then I desperately went oh I'm so
stupid
alright now we're caught up thanks for
bearing with me through that all right
now they're looking for a fuse box fuse
box it I cannot find because it's
nowhere to be found
absolutely nowhere is it in here is it
you you there open up [ __ ] imma get you
oh fusee fuse effuse you uh oh oh oh I'm
so oh I'm so stupid
I'm so stupid oh now I got a fine fuse
oh and the box of fuse is okay okay I
get it I get it I get it I gotta find
the fuses that's what I originally went
out for in the first place okay I looked
in all these containers they were empty
this looks like a very oh look it up
there ah that's fun that was fun hope
y'all enjoyed that something in here
that's useless okay okay okay okay
looking for random itty-bitty fuses that
are just lying around
I'm sure this this this will be fun and
entertaining to watch okay the uses fuss
says uh what does that mean oh all right
never mind I can't even act dumb I'm so
smart what do we got here huh who's
beeping shut up
give me your fuse get give me your fuses
I want it wanna give me okay
fragile a screw that go away
box nothing nope oh my god it's gonna
happen again I'm gonna get lost and
you're all gonna make fun of me oh
you're so gonna make fun of me don't
make fun of me please please I come to
your house up I'll beat you up
don't make fun of me hmm
out yeah again I did it Oh watchdog
really there it is
okay Oh dad I don't have the code
flammable Kabu well I guess this is
where the story ends cuz I'm too stupid
to find out where the next step is Oh
hope you all enjoyed this let's play I'm
never gonna do one again never ever ever
ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever
ever ever cuz I make myself look dumb oh
I'm so stupid busy maybe I picked one up
maybe I picked up oh maybe I mean no uh
uh uh probably maybe I can bust it open
oh yeah that's that's totally it
oh shut up John you don't know I'm so oh
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah maybe
alright alright I know I know I'm going
back to that radio room uh-huh uh-huh
yeah oh yeah hell yeah I got this don't
worry guys I know you never doubted me
for a second I know I didn't doubt
myself
alright I'm a radio up this [ __ ]
oh no no red red are you ready come on
yeah oh shut up John uh-huh
Oh God Oh
so man get out of the way to share oh oh
I'm a so dumb so dumb I'm gonna waste a
whole video
oh I'm oh just saw just scrap this video
oh I should just grab it I should scrap
it
Oh bunny hopping bunny hop bunny hop
bunny hop bunny hop bunny up plenty of
okay I've been in and out of this room
and that room many times nothing
a whole lotta nothing I'm going back to
that electrical room and I'm not coming
out until it's fixed
you better get ready power room uses
fuses fearo's eyes oh do I have a note I
should check my notes I should check
notes chuckles oh noes no so please tell
me to new ah [ __ ] you ah need to get
that fixed oh thanks okay all right oh
oh and gonna solve my problem [ __ ]
John oh [ __ ] you
Oh fix my promise I'll shut up oh oh oh
jump down the hole to my death oh oh oh
wait do I see something oh my god I see
something oh please please please oh god
oh please oh please believe you my
something shiny I saw something shiny no
no no I'm stupid oh oh oh oh oh don't
I'm dumb I'm dumb I'm dumb
oh I'm dumb oh I gotta do something oh I
gotta tell joke uh uh be entertaining
what's uh what's what's red and smells
like blue paint red paint hahaha okay oh
alright fine
Oh brain my brain my brain not brain
well time to once again make the
fruitless loop as I call it where I just
run in a circle for no reason
bonk bonk open up oh you're making a
buzzing sound I'm assuming that maybe
you're part of something important
bonk nope right I'm pretty sure that it
has to do with that room with the radios
in it
Oh God oh so dumb I'm so dumb
go away puppy I hate you shut up oh did
I check up there anything anything at
all oh no fault oh oh oh I didn't hurt
myself oh I'm learning I'm learning to
be a good not dying person okay alright
okay okay okay I've checked every
container check all these places
I'll smacked all these things even the
boxes and the stupid boxes be careful
I'll screw you I'll be whatever I want
to be which is dumb right now and I
found nothing
Oh
nothing at all I'm probably wasting
battery all right you're gonna hide here
in shame shame shame goodbye world
goodbye I'm all gift goodbye all rise
grid I'm tougher than that
I persevere oh oh a box of fusses why
you be all the contents can't be far
away
oh [ __ ] you far away maybe that's a
riddle oh not far away as in in the same
room room room jumpy jump ah you gotta
be kidding me
oh you got to be kidding me
ah no no no no get up I am oh okay
alright alright I've had it up to here
once again I'm pointing to the ceiling
with this puzzle coz that's stupid
I'm not stupid that's stupid that's
really stupid huh fine oh I should just
scrap this video but I won't because I
have more integrity than that oh right
get in there yeah get in there
alright yeah okay do I have to turn the
knobs again same order I did before the
right order y'all don't know this is
totally the right order
alright what a waste on my life not a
ways are your life because I'm sooo so
entertaining even though I was making an
ass out of myself on the entire Internet
alright I have a destiny to mate clunk
ah no ah ah okay
what am i view is I'm a deposit here and
so I don't waste any of your time I'm
gonna figure this [ __ ] out and then I'm
gonna serve the next part so I'll see
you in part 7 because this is ridiculous
bye bye